[Music]
Kevin oir welcome back to Virgin radio
Dubai on the Maz hakeim podcast I feel
like I live
here well I feel like you live here as
well it's so nice to have you back uh
last time we spoke you were in Abu Dhabi
you were doing a hiap of things uh tell
me what you've been up to since you've
been back in the UAE well I've been
coming to finance week in Abu Dhabi
every year and every year it grows
geometrically it was the biggest that's
ever been this year um there's there's a
fair amount of excitement about UAE with
investors because of so much activity
going on outside of the energy sectors
so as the as the policy here is to start
to diversify the economy there's a lot
of investment opportunities as a result
and uh just I mean every time I come
here I get more and more impressed in
terms of of how well this transition is
going and how many investment
opportunities there are um I was reading
an article in Bloomberg uh earlier this
week that said billionaire hedge fund
manager Alan Howard said that Abu Dhabi
could be a Global Financial Center after
London New York and Hong Kong do you
agree with him uh no it already is I
don't agree with him this is the capital
of capital this is growing faster than
any of those jurisdictions any of them
what really look for as an investor is
in growth yeah I mean the way you make
money when you invest is to invest in
growth opportunities uh you know New
York's a very important Market uh London
um Hong Kong has issues around China now
which not everybody loves uh but Abu
Dhabi has none of those it and it has
growth and so you know if you if you
have a choice where do I put if I had to
buy an index today in other words the
way to measure this as an investor if if
you had a choice which index would you
want to own for the next 5 years it
would be Abu Dhabi not any of the others
because there there's no way they're
going to grow this
fast what are some of those growth
opportunities like if someone didn't
really understand the finance world and
they wanted to make some Investments
what are some of those growth
opportunities in the UAE well let's
let's start with a very controversial
sector and it's very easy to understand
let's talk about cryptocurrencies and
digital payment systems that came
roaring on the scene in
2020 and the IT raised billions of
dollars given its growth potential
there's no question that blockchain will
become part of financial services it'll
in my view over the next 10 years become
the 12th sector of the S&P but the
platforms that were set up first and we
can mention their names because I
certainly remember them FTX and binance
now together they had 97% of the market
share of the world's cryptocurrencies
and potential for digital payments
because it's not just Bitcoin that this
is about it's about the ability to pay
people around the world using an using
an exchange now obviously we know what
happened to FTX and I remember because I
lost $18 million I'm not happy about
that and we've all seen what's happened
to binance and that happened faster than
anybody thought so those guys are gone
they're the they're the called them the
Pioneers but they now have arrows in
their backs and then whether it's
serendipitous luck or whether they
really thought this through or maybe a
little bit of both M2 just launched in
Abu Dhabi as the new home of crypto it
was a Fanfare event it's a private
company but it is all of what FTX was
and binance was except it's compliant
and it's backed by billions of dollars
and it's got massive financial
institutions attached to it yeah and
it's it's because it's compliant and
transparent you know who owns it it's
investable now the first thing I had to
figure out when I got here and watched
what was happening is as I said okay I
invest in exchanges I think if you could
have invested in the New York Stock
Exchange the day it was founded over 200
years ago and the NASDAQ and own those
through all the economic Cycles they
were fantastic Investments that's how I
feel about M2 so how do I get a piece
that's a problem it's private and so um
however you know I'm an industrious guy
I found out that Phoenix technology owns
30% of it Phoenix is going public on the
adx here in Abu Dhabi so then I have to
figure out how do I get a piece of
Phoenix I could buy the shares that's
what I found out so I'm using
international Securities which is the
biggest brokerage firm I could find in
Abu Dhabi I can download the app in the
US I set up an account I put it in order
and now I have access to M2 now as an if
you're an American you can't open an
account on M2 but you can own the stock
which is what I want and so that's what
I did I'm very excited about it and I
think this is going to be one of the
biggest exchanges in the world because
it's being built off the backbone of the
financial services sector of Abu Dhabi
totally compliant and and the the
management has already made their
announcements about how transparent
they're going to be I'm very excited
about this project so a lot of people
lost a lot money when it came to crypto
uh what do you have to say to people who
are a little bit hesitant in investing
again you know it doesn't what happened
with um sand bankman freed and Cy uh
they're no longer with us so to speak uh
they still alive though but that doesn't
change the
potential at all of what crypto can be
and I'll give you an example this is
this is a perfect example there's a
watch maker in Geneva named Simon Britt
he's the next Picasso of watchmaking
that's the buzz amongst collectors I'm a
big watch collector yes in fact I got
introduced to him through one of my
collector friends here right here in the
UAE and he's only going to make five
prototype watches and you have to be a
collector you've got to you know
petition him explain why you should own
it and luckily he agreed that I should
own number three now how do I pay for it
now when you're that kind of a guy and
you're well known you you get prepaid so
I had to figure out how do I transfer in
this case 40,000 Swiss Franks for the
down payment and 40,000 another 40,000
when it came time to to pick it up and
just by chance here we are sitting
together I'm picking it up tomorrow
morning at 11 o'clock in Geneva so I'm
going to leave here leave your wonderful
Studio get on a plane and fly to Geneva
to pick this watch up however I went
through hell to transfer the capital
from New York transferred into Swiss
Franks it took 3 days to do the wire
transfer then I got absolutely screwed
on the FX fees transferring it from US
Dollars into Swiss Franks and that took
even more time I'm getting screwed on
every level there which really makes me
unhappy I don't like to pay for
worthless Services if we had an M2 at
the time and I had an account on M2 and
Simon had an account on M2 I could
simply transfer
any currency I wanted to him or usdc or
a stable coin or Bitcoin whatever he
wants yeah in a split second at a
fraction of the cost so the potential of
what this could be is obvious in that Ed
Case except multiply that by a billion
times around the world and so somebody's
going to get it right someone's going to
be compliant someone's going to have the
capital to set this up I think it's
going to be M2 now you know this would
be my third time at best B you know I
did FTX struck out binance I'm so lucky
I didn't invest in that thing and now I
got one I can do that with I'm I'm
thinking this is going to be the one you
mentioned your watches what watches are
you wearing today I'm celebrating UAE
today because this is a Ming this is a
Ming watch and maybe I'm I'm saying
something out of school right now but
Ming has moved to the United arat
Emirates wow there's another sector
they're getting because he's found the
plat the platform here so compelling to
service the globe with his brand this
Ming is Ming's Ming except I bought it
it was on its way to his wrist the only
Ming so Ming's Ming's Ming is my
Ming on this side we have a Frank
Mueller watch that celebrates the U
Phoenix company you can see and I wore
it because you know I'm I'm now a
shareholder of Phoenix and that's the
Phoenix here this is number 9 of 50 and
it actually has a QR code to my digital
wallet when I decide to use it very
honored to have this piece and these are
I always wear two watches now the Ming
is is giving me uh UAE time and the
Phoenix watch is New York time so always
wear two watches otherwise how would you
know what time it is in New York or here
in UA you could watch you use your phone
but oh you're very expensive why would
you do that are you kidding no no I use
my phone for other stuff but for time I
got to use watches so for example I I'm
not a watch collector I don't know that
much about watches but if someone wants
to become a watch collector what is like
the first watch they should own well you
know the first rule that I tell
everybody because a lot of people follow
me around about watches and I really
like that I'm part of the watch
Community is never borrow money to buy a
watch never buy a watch outside of your
means because it's it's meant to capture
moments of your life upon your personal
successes or the birth of a child or
your marriage or something that when you
look at the face of the watch you
remember exactly why you bought it I
know exactly why and when I bought this
Ming I know exactly what this Phoenix
watch is about for the rest of my life
and
so you know I I make sure though that
you you start at a level you can afford
so if you're in early in your early 20s
I'd recommend a long jeene or maybe a
tutor and these are fantastic FC watches
you know there's all kinds of brands
that you can buy for under a th000 under
$2,000 or maybe 4,000 AED or whatever
you know sort of something entry level
and then as you are more successful buy
something else add to your collection as
I like to say and always bring in
diversity you want different dials
that's the whole idea so there's not
many places around the world that you
can wear your watches safely I remember
we spoke about this last time but you
can wear it in the UAE and there there
any moments of like Safety and Security
that you uh can talk about that you've
experienced in the UAE yesterday I
walked through um the compound the adgm
where we were holding the finance week I
had over a million dollars wor of
watches on my wrists um I would never do
that in any other city I feel 100% safe
and I wore them at night I walked back
to my hotel
at night with over a million dollars
with the watches on my wrist not worried
for a moment I have lost stuff when I'm
here only to have it returned to my
hotel room a day later yeah when an Uber
driver or taxi driver found it I mean
there's no place like this on Earth
there just isn't and I and you know when
people ask particularly if you look at
the ranking of a city like Abu Dhabi for
example it's been the safest city on
Earth for almost seven years and women
feel safe it's it's this is the it's the
people the culture the food the economy
the policy uh all of this stuff comes
together and the only way you're going
to appreciate is you got to come here
you know people say oh you know it's
just like another you know Middle
Eastern country they don't get it and
the reason they don't get it because
they haven't been here and so everybody
that comes here figures it out and says
wow I got to get I got to be part of
this at least if you're an investor you
do you know for me your portfolio should
have at least 5% waiting specifically in
the UAE given the growth of this
jurisdiction and you do it by using the
adx and so the adx is uh rapidly
becoming the exchange in the region and
there a lot of IPOs are coming here and
there's a a co-listing agreement I think
they just signed one with the New York
Stock Exchange last week so I'm all over
it so you know I open an account I have
an ad an adx account um Watch What
Happens Next if someone's never been to
the UAE why should they come here other
than what they see on
Instagram um well I look at it from the
perspective of an investor I mean um
there the it's it's one word it's growth
yeah it it UAE equals growth that's
exactly what it is and so I look at it
that way but also you have to understand
how to work with the regulator here what
I found interesting about the last week
I've been here I I got access to
leadership I was able to sit down and
talk to them about the different areas
I'm interested in investing in they
pointed me to other entrepreneurs that
already done it so I can buy into their
deals uh it's very Cooperative it's very
transparent it's very open um and the
regulator is is is wide open to discuss
what you can and can't do here and so
all the Professional Services law firms
that I use in New York are established
here the audit firm we use our regulator
we understand what we have to do so a
lot of infrastructure has been uh put to
work over the last I'd say 15 20 years
here and it's it's wide open for
business and that's why you find
billions of dollars coming here I
mean you
know they get the joke here you know
what I mean that they understand what
they need to do to be successful and
they're doing it the agenda for Dubai in
20133 was revealed earlier this year to
double the size of Dubai's economy over
the next decade how can we or the
average person capitalize on these
opportunities very simply open an
account I'm going to the one that the
one I did I put it on my phone it's
actually on my phone I downloaded this
app in New York City okay I open my adx
account in New York City it it was done
that easily and all I'm doing to get
exposure to that economic growth is
buying the index 30 companies IES
trading together in an ETF right here on
my phone so you know I'm I'm just being
transparent I wired in a million US
Dollars and I said I'm going to start
buying the the index here and I bought
some of that uh Phoenix IPO yeah as well
so you know for me it's for right now
it's a 5% waiting because but if you
there isn't a single country in the
world right now that can make the
statement you just made about growth
yeah so why wouldn't you want 5% of that
in your portfolio and the way you want
to own it is and I'll I'll actually tell
you I'm going to disclose what I'm
buying okay okay um because I I I did a
lot of work for example there is an ETF
in the US called UAE and I I looked at
that and said well why would I need to
open an account in the UAE if I could
just buy the UAE yeah but then I looked
at what was inside of it and why was it
not performing like the UAE index was M
there missing IHC the biggest holding
company in the region $280 billion
company missing in that index yes well
that's a mistake so the index let me
find it for you that I'm actually going
to buy that Kevin includes it is
CH that chesh is all of the companies
you want to own in one ETF so that's
very easy for me tra fees are fractional
here I mean it's one of the lowest fees
there are but for me this is a Buy and
Hold I buy that I just hold it so right
if if they're successful in doubling the
economy Mr Wonderful is going to make a
lot of
money so other than adx what else can
the average person invest in well I
think what's interesting and I'll give
you an example why am I here
incorporating o Global because that's
why I'm here this time that's why I've
spent more time I had to get all the
infrastructure in place started hiring
people let me tell you my number one
cost since I last saw you so I have a
pretty large portfolio of companies
during the pandemic they changed all of
them changed their business models to
more of a direct consumer strategy yeah
so that means they have to acquire
customers so they used to go through
distribution these are consumer goods
and services maybe a car 4 in Europe or
maybe a Target or Walmart in the United
States whatever today they want to
acquire the customer to get the data
service them directly at a higher gross
margin because if you're selling direct
consumer your only costs are acquiring
that customer manufacturing the product
and shipping it to them now the big
problem is the cost of acquiring the
customer which means you have to
generate content create social media put
it on social put it on radio put it on
television put it on whatever and get
the customer to learn about it that
production cost for us is costing us
Millions a month millions of dollars a
month millions and going up like crazy
shoot it edit it produce it post-
produce it cut it for Tik Tok make it
for Instagram make it different for
LinkedIn it's expensive and I thought to
myself what could reduce the
cost AI if we've already shot it there's
terabytes of Television I've been doing
for 20 years why not just create AI
Kevin and tell everybody it's it's the
AI guy and so when you see me soon it'll
be the AI Mr Wonderful wow and by the
way he's going to speak 48 languages
think about that so I can make I can
make content just for the French in V
the Canton of v Switzerland which is a
different dialect than what they speak
in Paris which is different what they
speak in Quebec I mean AI Kev I'm love
this guy and he's much cheaper and I'm
so I'm licensing myself to myself so I I
can sue myself in case I don't like what
myself said that's exactly what I'm
going to do and I'm not the only guy
doing this the question is where is the
talent to do it well number one in terms
of dollars invested in AI as United
States number two China where's number
three United Emirates with a better tax
policy so that's where I'm doing it
that's we're going to generate all this
content right here in our offices in o l
Global right in Abu Dhabi that's the
plan over the next 24 months yeah I saw
a lot celebrities are not entirely
comfortable with the a AI version of
themselves but me I love Mr Wonderful I
love him and I'm going to love him even
more when he can speak all these
languages it's going to be fantastic we
write the script we say let's target for
the Swiss market
boom there he is speaking of P France
maywe that's what's going to happen yeah
let's talk real estate so the UAE is a
hub for Real Estate Investments have you
noticed any Trends or where should
people invest in different areas in the
UAE you know commercial real estate is
one sector of real estate I do a lot in
real estate but you know
residential in in in particularly in the
growth in cities like Dubai and Abu
Dhabi um is for me the more interesting
sector because what happens here is
people and I've watched this with people
I know you come once and you kind of get
Feel For What It's Like and then you
come again and you start to you know
build contexts meet government talk to
other investors and then you start
saying to yourself okay um there's some
projects here I'd like to look at in my
case it's Ai and I talked about digital
currencies and payment systems those are
the two big areas for me right now um
and then you say to yourself well okay
I've been staying in hotels for weeks at
a time maybe I should get a place to to
live so you want condo with Services
obviously because maybe you're going to
travel to the to the region 6 months of
the year maybe six months in a day if
you're doing a tax strategy um that to
me is where things get interesting
because a a lot of you know I just look
at the four years I've been coming to
Abu Dhabi it doesn't even look like it
did four years ago yeah I mean there's
so many cranes here and that's because
there's fundamental demand and and I
think that's part of when you're
investing in a hold Co like IHC you're
getting exposure to that because they
invest in that too they've got hundreds
of companies within that one public
stock IHC it's massive you can buy that
or it's also 50% of the waiting of that
ETF I gave you earlier so it's or close
to it I mean so the whole idea is you
get exposure to all sectors by just
buying the index that's my strategy it's
much easier than trying to pick an
individual stock do you own a lot of
homes around the world I do I do and you
know people should understand that homes
have capital appreciation that's good
but they negative Cash Flow To You for
maintenance and taxes and it's a
nightmare and once you get past four you
don't have enough days in the year to
spend enough time in any one place so I
feel very sorry for my wife she's now a
property manager and it's driving her
crazy and and we're trying because you
there's always something going wrong or
the elevator or the road or the taxes or
you know um we own homes in Florida in
Boston in Geneva in Canada and you know
I almost feel homeless because I don't
know where to go next you know but I'm
doing it because I'm an investor and I
invest in these countries not so much in
Canada yet uh as I like to say and I I I
feel I'm allowed to say this because I
am a Canadian citizen it's the richest
country on Earth run by idiots and so
I'm waiting for the management there to
change because I don't put money to work
there you can't get anything done there
you can't get permits you can't do
anything but uh Justin Trudeau who's the
Prime Minister I will give him his
accolades very successful politician
worst manager I have ever seen I
wouldn't let him manage a candy store
for me he he'd be bankrupt within a week
I mean the guy is the very worst manager
there is but that you can have a
successful politician and have idiot
management at the same time you don't
have that problem here the executional
skills at in each mandate whether it's
the adx meet the management there or
whether it's in you know biotech or or
G40 g42 for example where I got my my
DNA sequenced yes I mean leadership here
finds the best executional skills
regardless of their nationality and puts
them in those seats now that's
management that's management that's
that's like this this country is is run
like a well-oiled machine with
executional skills is the primary
mandate regardless of where you were
born or what your nationality is
leadership hero puts that person in that
role boom and it works that's how you
run a country Trevor Noah at his comedy
show was joking about how every time he
comes back every three months even
Google Maps says no you can't build here
and the UAE is like yep we're building
here yeah I mean I mean the the whole
point is you have to have a master plan
you have to have good policy you have to
be competitive you got to be safe you
got to have things where you know school
and and health care for
families the best food in the world is
here every restaurant I know is here I
mean I it's it's I just went to Cafe
Milano uh at the Hilton in Abu Dhabi
last night yes I mean spectacular ve if
it's a free you know it's Shameless
promotion for them fantastic ve what are
some of your favorite restaurants in the
UAE when you come here I you know I like
some of the classics but the ones that
I've had the most fun with is finding on
the Harbor here in in in Dubai for
example I found the best Lebanese food
I've ever had and Lebanese food is hard
to make and so you caught Lebanese right
yeah I'm I'm half Irish half Lebanese so
in the Lebanese culture the it's
matriarchal and the grandmother runs the
show and my grandmother never spoke a
word of English and um but you know she
I used to love she came from hasbaya
which is north of Beirut and she moved
with her husband to to Montreal Canada
and I was born there and she loved
apples so she they bought a farm and she
and he ran a a clothing company called
Kitty togs and all of his all of her
daughters work for the the father but
the the the grandmother um runs the show
and she used to get my brother and I to
pick the apples off the trees but she'd
hand select each one with a stick so
she'd make us go up the ladder and and
hit us and point to the one she wanted
we'd have to pick that one and I said to
my mom what is this I what am I slave
labor here I'm not even getting paid
anything for this and she's
just used to say to me which is a swear
word in Arabic and just you know hit me
with a stick and she was doing that to
pick the apples for the apple pie on the
Sunday night dinner which happened at
4:30 to 5:00 all the women would prepare
it all day and the family would gather
run by the matriarch and I've really
resented it in those days but now I
appreciate it so much yeah I do it my
own family wow but that's how I grew up
she was tough and and I women were
always a big part of my life no question
and uh I noticed on your Instagram you
were doing a medical treatment and you
were talking about how uh Medical in the
UAE and in Abu Dhabi in particular is so
Advanced are you into biohacking what's
your routine like and what treatment
were you getting oh I'm way past that
I'm way past that
I'm actually a vampire I'm going to live
260 years so I'm just making sure I stay
healthy the the uh the advancement here
are extraordinary I'll give you an
example two years ago I was um listening
to management make a
presentation um at g42 about the
sequencing lab they had and they had the
very best of the Chinese the British and
the American system there's no place
like that on Earth because those guys
are all suing each other but not here
because leadership is supporting their
research yes and the the morning
before I had received my residency card
my golden Visa yes um and he was
explaining that every citizen of the UAE
was offered free DNA sequencing and to
turn the toggles on or off to see you
know what the what the precursor was for
them in their lives and what they should
be concerned about and I just put up my
hand and said excuse me and I showed him
my I think I have it on me I carry go
here I'm very proud of it I'm very proud
of it but it's a very useful uh I do
have it here it is right here so I I put
this I held this up right there I have
one too isn't that F and I said I have
one of these can I have my DNA sequence
yes I want the full monty and he said
absolutely uh the limo followed me back
to the hotel got a stool sample urine
sample blood sample all that stuff and
four or five days later I sent it to the
coronell research lab in New York which
I'm part of a longevity study at and
Richard isacson the head researcher at
the time looked at and said he had never
seen resolution like that the amount of
data we got from that and it changed all
the protocols of what I was doing in
terms of Maintenance which supplements I
take the protocols and my diet and
everything as a result of that I lost 32
pounds I have more energy than I've ever
had but there's so many different
procedures here that you can't get
anywhere else and I just what you saw
this morning yeah was a treatment that I
I came for that I'm very excited about
I'm starting that so when every time I
come here I spend a day in in getting
all of these procedures that I can't get
anywhere else what people should
understand about United Emirates and
again I'm going to give credit to
leadership for figuring out this policy
they invest billions in
prevention they'd rather you didn't get
sick yeah because the cost of most
societies of people that don't take care
of themselves is billions of dollars why
not invest in keeping healthy so if you
want to be healthy and you want to you
know get access to incredible treatments
this is it this is the country you come
to and so another reason why I I you
know I come over so often now is one of
those days I'm going to sit on that
gurnie going through the full cleansing
procedure and everything else I can get
here um there's no place like it on
Earth I keep saying that because it's
true there's no place like it on Earth
uh so what's your morning routine like
what's your evening routine like what
does Mr Wonderful do uh to keep himself
young and energetic I get up at about
5:45 um and read the research primarily
out of Asia and the bond markets they
tell you so much and I I work out from 6
to about
7:30 um it takes about an hour and a
half an hour 20 minutes and and while
I'm doing that I'm listening to
financial services podcasts and and
research it's a routine you get into a
retune a you know routine and and
wherever I go here there's a good gym so
I did it every day this week um have
breakfast and then start my work day and
I break the day out into 30 minute
meetings I'm very fortunate I don't have
to do anything anymore but I want to so
I make sure I'm spending my time in the
most fruitful way I can in the things
that interest me and so right now I'm
hot to trot on AI for reasons we talked
about I need to spend time checking out
my watch collection deciding which 17
watches I'm going to wear this week I
wear six a day two uh from breakfast to
lunch switch at lunch to and then my my
killer watches at night and what I love
about this place is I can wear them all
I don't have to worry about somebody
stealing it from me so you know I'm I'm
very interested in showcasing what I've
got because there's a lot of collectors
I like here and these are things that
interest me I try and play my guitar
every day um just you know you got that
and yang the Arts and whatever and I I I
try and spend time with friends and and
business associates and I always uh
schedule a you know a dinner here at at
mixed business and pleasure try a new
restaurant I mean it's there's a lot to
do here obviously and then new
initiatives like setting up L Global is
keeping me very busy and we're doing
that my Director of Finance has been
here now for two and a half weeks and
she's not leaving promised you this
until we take in our first first million
do wow which is going to be in a couple
of days and so we're redirecting a lot
of our business through our o l Global
now for a plethora of reasons but you
know we we're our first our first it's
always you want to you want to you know
Mark it with the first million and
that's coming I think probably Wednesday
this week that's so wonderful I know
you're a vampire and you're going to
live to 250 years old but will you pass
a lot of your Finance a lot of your
responsibilities and your money to your
children or no that's not that's not my
plan at all that that was not the deal
um that my parents did to me and and
because my mother had this thing about
entitlement she hated entitlement and
her her big expression was the dead bird
under the nest never learned how to fly
and I've said this countless times this
story because when I graduated from
college uh I didn't have a job and she
said listen good news is I'm coming for
the graduation bad news is no more
checks and I said what are you talking
about I don't have a job she said not
paying for anything else you got to go
make it on your own and you know I had a
tough couple of years but it certainly
motivated me to go figure it out and
I've done the same policy with my own
kids and it doesn't mean I don't take
care of them uh if there's an illness in
the family but my trust is provides uh
for children even out of wedlock from
birth to last day of college and then
they get nothing yeah and when I when I
explained that to my son when he was uh
you doing very poorly in high school um
in Boston was going to school yeah he
you know he just thought well you know I
have a trust fund I don't have to worry
I said yeah you do until you you're out
of school then you have nothing and he
just freaked out he was I said yeah yeah
know but you can do whatever you want
with the rest of your years in education
you can get a PhD you on it's all on me
uh and and he he's going to study for a
no he cracked down he became an
electrical engineering now he works at
Tesla he's an engineer at Tesla he's
doing just fine and he can fend for
himself he's making more money at his
age than I ever made then and so you
know I'm confident and my daughter's
very successful she produces Comm
commercials for the Air Force in um in
the United States yeah I mean my kids
were Americans and they're they're they
grew up in Boston and um I'm uh Irish
I'm Canadian and I'm an emirati um
resident and I really want a passport so
I'm working hard on that I mean that's I
I want to earn it I want to be part of
the family here I think you already are
I hope so how many posss you said you
have you have Irish Canadian and working
on this because I I I just feel that uh
you know I I think it's partly my
culture the the Lebanese culture is very
much part of
the the the UAE reminds me of of Lebanon
and it reminds me of Cypress where I
grew up and it it's got except it its
economy is way more successful yeah good
policy good policy I mean somebody
really thought the policy through that
made this work this country is only 50
plus years old M and it's beating most
economies in the world so everybody
could learn something by the way they
run this place mhm if you were 25 now
and you had to remake all your money
what would you do if someone's listening
now and they want to make a little bit
of money but they don't know where to
start I'd mov to Abu
Dhabi yeah you know there's that old
saying in that movie Plastics you know
you move here there's just so many
growth sectors you know people uh are
ignorant about um UAE and they think
that everything is energy you know
what's interesting at Finance week I
don't think we talked about energy once
like you know five years ago that's what
you talk about but I don't think I heard
the word hydrocarbon once it's all about
other sectors that are growing there's a
lot of excitement about AI we talked
about it there's a lot of excitement of
digital payments systems there's a lot
of excitement about everything and it's
which means that the strategy to
diversify the economy away from energy
is working and you know even hosting the
UN climate conference today it starts
today it's here which makes a lot of
sense to me because what you find in
terms of advanced technology um and and
I'm planning to try and bring some of
this back we run a mandate for the state
of North Dakota and we're expanding that
so we're we're investing in North Dakota
and we need carbon sequestration well a
lot of the Advanced Technologies were
adapted here first and so we're going to
bring some of that back there there's a
lot of you know there's a lot you can
learn here that's already been done here
a lot of some very interesting
technology already been spent here um so
you just have to do the work but you
will find you you talk to any Minister
and say look I'm I'm interested in this
they'll tell you Five Guys to call right
away they know and so we did that with
AI we immediately found one of the
biggest producers here and said let's
experiment with you let's try your
technology uh and see how you can do Mr
Wonderful that speaks Arabic so putting
your Shark Tank hat on if are you still
investing in people's businesses small
businesses or oh yeah I I do probably uh
15 to 20 deals a year that's a lot
multis sectoral some are very large
Investments some are very small uh we
have a great team it's it's being it's
being built up we obviously are had no
idea that Shark Tank would become this
big a platform ever we had no idea it's
going into its 16th season it's Global
it's on in 42 countries um you know it's
it's afforded me such an incredible
platform that I'm thankful for every day
uh a young Indian boy this morning uh
said to me at at I was having breakfast
at the Hilton on Yaz Island and he came
running down with his cell phone he
couldn't have been more than 9 years old
and he said I want to be just like you
wow love it that's so wonderful and he
watched Shark Tank and he's here in in
uh Dubai and I said what do you mean
like me he said I really want to be an
entrepreneur I said great that's good so
he's learning that that's fantastic so
if someone wants to be an entrepreneur
they want to be like you they want to be
successful what are a couple of tips as
a investor uh would you give them to be
a successful entrepreneur you're going
to fail you have to learn that you know
eight out of 10 times you're going to
lose your money um maybe even more
sometimes but the two that are
successful out of 10 deals are going to
pay for all your mistakes you have to
learn that the the thing I've learned
the most mostly by working with
successful you know what what I find
interesting is over just take shark tank
for example over 15 years 75% of my
successes have come from companies run
by women which and they don't even know
each other they're just multi sectoral
you know just different deals and what
what I've learned from them and I tell
everybody I work with now is you have to
you have to learn how to separate the
signal from the noise great managers set
goals each day and they they don't let
they don't they're not they're not
distracted they say that's not important
I'm not going to waste any time on that
I'm going to get the things done that I
need to get done those are the people
you want to invest in because they have
their ear to the track they see the
train coming down the track before it
runs them over they don't get distracted
and there's so many inputs these days of
uh of noise so the ability to to to
Really separate the signal from the
noise is Paramount if you're going to be
an entrepreneur you have to learn how to
do that you will fail if you don't do
that you will def you will fail because
you're you're trying to make everybody
happy which you can't do yeah don't even
try make yourself happy and and get your
thing get your goals done you you need
to get three big things done every day
that's what I teach them how important
is positive thinking when it comes to
your your day-to-day life or success
well the interpretation of that is not
to let challenges stress you in other
words if if if you can't deal with
pressure uh because you're going to be
always Under Pressure there's always
such so much stuff coming at
you the way you you stay in control is
you you realize it goes back to that
identify that issue that is noise that
is ues noise I don't care about that but
I do care about this and if if you if
you can find the signal you'll always be
in control and you'll always be happier
because you're getting stuff done it's
PE and I can identify people now that
don't know how to do that and I really
make sure I don't invest in them because
they are they're going to be miserable
they're going to be running around like
a chicken with their head cut off
they're going to lose a lot of money and
they're never going to figure it out you
need um I I you know particularly that
old adage you want something done give
it to a busy mother a mother can
separate the signal from the noise and
they can be very successful in business
as a result of learning that talent that
signal and noise is that energy do you
believe in energy it's the ability to
analyze uh in the moment it's it's I do
believe in energy obviously and and you
you need to take care of yourself you
know part of it
is if you want to be successful you have
to have a healthy mind too you have to
take care of your body you have to take
care of your mind you have to eat well
don't smoke don't drink too much you
know it's sort of common sense but many
young entrepreneurs say I'm going to
work 20 hours a day I'm going to sleep
four hours a night that's stupid you
will definitely fail like I don't want
anybody to do that for me that's just so
dumb I want you to be healthy eat well
exercise do ying and yang in other words
chase the Arts something chaotic and at
the same time business is very binary
it's black and white white you need both
in your life those are successful
managers and you know frankly um it's
it's the idea that that you you can do
all of these things and stay focused and
be happy doing that that gets you to a
very good place it's a very Gary ve
approach the 20 yeah I know Gary we know
each other and and he and I agree on
this um you know in a big way and and
he's been very successful because you
know if if you to do
to work like this and I I I work a lot
and I and I enjoy what I do I have to
want to do it I I want to I want it to
represent who I am I you know I work I
don't know 12 14 hours a day but it's
not work to me it's what exactly what I
want to do I don't do anything I don't
want to do I don't have to so and I work
I work with a great team and we break
the day into 30 minute segments and we
just I want to be here you know I'm
going to spend an hour with you because
it's it's it's it's great and and I want
to tell my story and I'm very excited
about being part of the community here
in the UAE and you're very much part of
the way you communicate to the UAE
that's for sure I learned that the first
time we worked together everybody told
me they they heard it yeah so you have a
big audience here thank you so much
what's next for Mr
Wonderful um lots of AI Mr Wonderful
well next for me that I'm very excited
about is tomorrow morning pick picking
up my Simon Brett
watch then I'm going to meet uh with my
Swiss Banker that those guys are tough
I'm meeting them for lunch I'm seeing my
93y old dad um I'm going to spend a
couple of days with him he's in perfect
health it's amazing and then um I'm
going to fly to New York and I'm
shooting a whole bunch of television and
I you know what's going to happen next
week everybody there I'm going to I do a
lot of networks and a lot of outlets in
the US every time I come back from from
Abu Dhabi Finance week they say okay
what happened in Abu Dhabi I always say
to them why don't you go there yourself
but like what am I the messenger boy
here but I'm going to tell them what
happened you know and and exactly these
subtle changes between one year and the
next and and we'll be talking about that
next week and then I'm going to be um
you know the holidays are coming uh
there there's a lot of a lot of stuff
I'm doing I'm launching a new business
um called Wonder care which provides
watch Insurance Wonder care.com
partnering with chub and hinky so that
one of my biggest problems is I don't
need to ensure the watches that are
under the street in a Zurich Vault I
need to ensure the 17 to 20 watches I
travel with and so I just want to ensure
those and I want to use my phone to buy
that insurance for a two we period that
kind of thing I've solved with with
Wonder care um AI is a big deal I'm
going to be coming back here in early
February I've got a plethora of meetings
set up for stage two of what I'm doing
okay so I'm trying to use my time
effectively but um you know it's it's it
it's just I try and map it out quarter
by quarter and what is Mr Wonderful
doing over the Christmas period oh well
I'm going to try you know my I always
say to my family and this is again you
know I'm very fortunate to be able to do
this where do you want to be each
weekend what pick any city on earth
bring boyfriends girlfriends whatever I
don't care let's gather as a family for
Friday right through Monday morning pick
a city and this year um I'm not a big
fan of snow anymore but my kids want to
be have the holiday with snow which
I well I like to see pictures of white
Christmas but I'd rather have my toes in
the sand on the beach but this year
we're going going to enjoy Christmas day
in the snow and then the right after
that we're going to get on a plane and
go to Miami Beach where we have a place
I I I like the I'm a beach person you
know what happened to me was I I
experienced um I there was a famagusta
was a beach in Cypress and I grew up in
nicasa I went to the junior school there
and Beach culture is you know part of
the cypri at lean KN kind of thing and
and we used to go to the trotus
mountains and cook a goat and I learned
how to be a chef you know in those years
but that that that's very much part of
the culture I want to get back to now I
find it here I I need the ocean and I
need a beach and I need sand in my
elevator in my condo which means it goes
right down onto the beach I can get that
Miami I can get it here in Abu Dhabi
that's the that's why I need that that
gives me my energy because I like to
ride my bike uh you know on the
boardwalk or walk the beach you know
collect your thoughts near the ocean I
think once you grow up in the
Mediterranean it's very hard to sort of
go away from that natural sort of
Lifestyle yeah you're right you're right
and also I really miss that kind of food
now now that I care a lot about what I
eat yeah we have very very healthy food
here and it's it's you can you you know
you can eat really well and that's
that's that's how you get a lot of
energy you just you just watch your diet
during the day and it gives you a lot of
power Andrew hub man says that the
Mediterranean diet is one of the best
diets that you can have yeah oh yeah I
mean and I recommend the Lebanese
version of it everybody has their own
favorites but I can get all of that food
here um I consider food as medicine
that's you know when I when I'm when I'm
feeling you know tired or whatever I I
eat well and I kind of bring that back
um I look I I I just think you get into
a you find a Zone and you get into it
and I think uh you have to find places
in the world where you can do that where
you can work and and live at the same
time this is certainly one of them it's
been such an absolute pleasure when are
you back in the UAE I will be back the
first week of February I think we're
just making those plans now perfect
timing the weather's great you know New
York's not so great February so I will
be visiting it by Zoom call from here
that's it thank you so much see you next
time when you're in the UA thank you
it's been great